là c'est moi je m'appelle laglais
j'avais une petite vie bien tranquille
sa vamp leurs données j'adorais mon
métier je provoquer des accidents
les crash tests t'es pas au courant au
courant de quoi en plus tu connais vous
d'elle même en cette lettre nous
expliquer que les ij était plus rentable
et que elle elle était localisée à
l'étranger 1 castrés avec a eu je crois
que je vais garder mon emploi vous vous
voulez être muté en inde c'est bien pour
vivre l'un d'eux tu vas aller [ __ ] en
inde tu vas faire ça
j'ai déjà pris ma décision j'aimerais
bien avec toi ça devait pas été
compliqué de leur non tu ne vois tu es
ou plus elle en voiture
[Musique]
tu parle pas beaucoup toi et penfao par
un cheval
souvent pas les français tut avec vente
donne enfin de skype ans
we going to enjoy
ça bientôt un petit creux non
enfin non
when it on
[Musique]
j'étais pas quelqu'un qui manifestaient
qu'ils séquestraient des dirigeants qui
pourraient l'aider pneus ou qui a
revendiqué ces droits je suis au milieu
du désert il ya des militaires partout
j'ai été juste quelqu'un qui préférait
accepter un boulot de maire demande
plutôt que de se remettre en question
c'est pour ça que je continue
[Musique]
et ouverte à tous